oh good morning everybody for the first
time in almost a year the knights were
allowed to have a limited number of fans
at their games this week
2600 to be exact and it worked everybody
was happy the fans were happy the
knights were happy and
oh by the way they won both their games
she had such a good time tonight dancing
and celebrating the win
yeah it's just like old times well sort
of there's only 2600 fans in the games
now
it's working right now for the fans and
for the players doesn't matter if it's
five new fans or
thousands of new fans we know that
they're going to bring a lot of energy
and emotion
to the building and there's no fans like
vegas fans so we're really excited and
we want to play well for them and it was
just amazing
to be able to share this experience with
them
and to get a golden knights win it was
just absolutely amazing
you know the best fans in the league but
i'll say it because
they deserve to hear it and you know
they were right there with us all the
way tonight and
the anthem when they said nice uh it
wasn't just uh
will carrier and ryan reeves yelling it
on the bench or the blue line there was
uh thousands of fans yelling and uh had
a
had a little bit of a smile on my face
that's for sure and we knew that they
were going to be with us all night and
it was going to be really exciting
and it looks like that number will
increase coming up and who knows perhaps
even
half full or even more by the start of
the stanley cup playoffs in mid-may the
knights by the way head out on the road
for their next six games scheduled
they've got weekend games
at san jose then it's off to minnesota
and st louis next week
i'm ron futrell eight sports now